-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How is everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
President Biden spoke on Monday
from his coronavirus quarantine
to announce that the U.S.
had killed Al Qaeda leader
Ayman al-Zawahiri,
which kind of sets
unreasonable expectations
about how much work
we're supposed to get done
while having COVID.
You ordered the killing of
Al Qaeda's top guy with COVID.
I didn't even tell jokes
about it while I had COVID.
According to a new report,
U.S. intelligence officials
killed Al Qaeda leader
Ayman al-Zawahiri
after tracking him down
through his family.
Yet another reason not to accept
a Facebook friend request
from your aunt.
"Is that a drone?
Peggy!"
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
said in a new interview
that she has dinner
with President Biden most nights
and they turn off the television
to spend time together.
Also, nothing good's on
at 4:00 p.m.
[ Laughter ]
The First Lady also said that,
despite her busy schedule,
she gets 7 1/2 hours
of sleep most nights.
Apparently, her secret is asking
Joe to tell her about his day.
"You're not going to
believe this part."
"Mm-hmm."
Ahead of Missouri's
Republican Senate primary,
former President Trump on Monday
posted to his Truth Social
platform
that he was endorsing Eric
but did not mention
whether it was former
Governor Eric Greitens
or State Attorney General
Eric Schmitt.
Said Trump, "Neither. Menendez."
[ Laughter ]
It's not too soon, is it?
Oh, just too bad?
Just keep him up
a second longer.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
departed Taiwan today
without incident
after weeks of tension
with China over the visit.
I mean,
that's playing with fire,
an 82-year-old getting on
a plane right now?
U.N. Secretary General
Antonio Guterres on Monday
said that humanity is, quote,
"one miscalculation away
from nuclear annihilation."
It was the worst
best man speech ever.
According to the latest numbers,
after Taco Bell bought --
brought back, excuse me --
the Mexican pizza to its menu
in May,
demand was seven times higher
than when the item
was previously available.
Also seven times higher?
The people ordering them.
[ Laughter ]
"Does that say Mexican pizza?"
And finally, New York's MTA
announced plans last week
to provide cellphone service
while traveling
between stations.
No word on whether they also
plan to offer train service.
It will be helpful to have
the cellphone service.
No, it's not.
It's not here.
That was a monologue,
everybody.